KORY JEFFREY: Welcome everybody.
We are live at location at
Founder World in San Francisco.
Joining me in the
studio is Sanjit Dang,
Investment Director
at Intel Capital.
Thank you for
joining me, Sanjit.
SANJIT DANG: Thank you very
much for having me here.
KORY JEFFREY: So let's talk a
little bit about Intel Capital.
What is, I believe,
your consumer?
SANJIT DANG: Well,
let me step back.
We are the venture arm
of Intel, the company.
And our goal is to
create new markets
and expand existing
markets for Intel.
We have been investing
for 25 years.
And we are one of the most
active investors, not just
most active corporate
investors, but
actually, one of the
most active investors.
We invest around $400
million every year.
So that's not a fund size.
That's actually every year.
And we have been doing
it for a lot of years.
So it's not just talk.
In fact, this year, we are
on track to do $600 million
in startups.
So very active investors.
Very global as well.
We have a strong presence
in Asia, Europe, everywhere.
So mirroring Intel as a company.
KORY JEFFREY: Does that spread
across different stages?
SANJIT DANG: It goes across
consumer, enterprise.
We invest in data center space,
big data, cloud computing,
dev ops.
We invest on consumer
side, e-commerce, media,
drones, you name it, wearables.
So we are actually quite
agnostic because Intel
as a company is a
horizontal company.
We want to be the underlying
layer of computing everywhere.
So mirroring that is
the investment thesis
of Intel Capital.
KORY JEFFREY: So would you say
the investment thesis is, then,
investing in markets where
you guys can be the underlying
computing engine?
SANJIT DANG: Yeah.
And we don't need to have
a hardware partnership
with the startup when we invest.
But if we can see
a vision how this
can be beneficial
to Intel long-term,
that is what we are looking for.
And there is actually
a second play
that has come up within Intel
in the last three, four years,
a 3D camera called RealSense.
The goal of that camera is to
provide vision to all devices.
So today, it is already selling
into the laptops and tablets.
Next, we actually have a
partnership with Google
that we announced where we
are putting the RealSense
camera behind the phones.
So if you Google search for
"Intel RealSense Google,"
you will see prototypes
of the phones.
So our vision is that
phones will have 3D cameras.
So next, I should be able
to just move the phone,
tell what's the dimensions
of that wall, how
the furniture will look
like in virtual world
before doing any
shopping or calling
any contractor to my home.
So in addition to
the compute layer,
we are also looking for
investment opportunities
where we can bring new
applications and usages
to the RealSense camera.
KORY JEFFREY: Interesting.
So walk me through.
If I'm an entrepreneur, how do
you get involved with Intel?
How do you get discovered?
How do you like to interact
with the entrepreneur
to move towards an investment?
SANJIT DANG: For
me, I really have
to build some trust
and credibility
with the entrepreneur.
That's supreme.
And I have to be able to have
a dialogue with him or her.
It's not just about
the presentation.
In some pitches, I just say,
OK, the presentation is great.
Let's do a whiteboard session.
I want to get into the mind
of the entrepreneur, how
sharp the person is, what
he or she is thinking.
What's the vision of
this entrepreneur?
Especially when we are investing
at seed and Series A level,
there's not enough market
proof for these startups.
So it's very important
to understand
what the team is thinking.
And it's also important to get
comfortable about their ability
to attract more talent.
Because typically,
we come across a team
of 5 or 10 people.
But once we invest,
let's say, $10 million,
the next stage is
going to be hiring.
How do you get to
20 people, 30, 40?
They have to be able to
attract the right talent.
And if they can't articulate
the vision of the company
to me as an investor, how will
they convince future talent?
How will they convince future
employees or their customers?
So that's what I'm looking for.
KORY JEFFREY: Makes sense.
So if vision is a
big, critical aspect
for you guys in
investing, would you
say that you invest in ideas
that go far into the future?
SANJIT DANG: We are.
We already are.
3D cameras, that's
a great example.
Very few devices today
actually have 3D cameras.
But we believe in that vision.
We believe that all
devices over time
will have a 3D camera just
like a 2D camera today.
So we're already
investing in startups that
are driving along that vision.
We already made
investments here.
KORY JEFFREY: So we've
talked a lot about Intel
being a very horizontal company.
And so you're a little
bit technology agnostic
in terms of where you invest.
You're not verticalized.
But what is a technology
or a recent investment
that you've done that's
really got you excited?
SANJIT DANG: That
got me excited?
I invested in DocuSign.
DocuSign is an
e-signatures company.
We did the investment
earlier this year.
And we really like how they
have been able to execute.
This is not just
about the vision,
but how they have
been able to execute
in that space, digital
management space,
and be able to pretty
much command the market,
not just in the US, but
even outside the US.
And we really liked the product
at a fundamental level-- very
sticky, nice user interface,
very convenient for the user,
and it gets the job done on
a mobile phone very quickly.
KORY JEFFREY: So we're
at Founder World.
There's thousands
of people here.
What is it that you look for?
What brings you to
an event like this?
SANJIT DANG: I always
crave for some new ideas
that challenge me, that
when I hear, I go, wow.
I would have never been
able to think about it.
This would have never
crossed my mind.
I actually learn
from entrepreneurs.
And I enjoy being in the company
of entrepreneurs, to be honest.
They come up with
such creative ideas,
and they're very dogmatic
about their vision.
That's what I like
about entrepreneurs.
So I talk to, whether
it's a one-person
shop or a three-people
shop or a 50-people shop,
they're all equal in my mind.
The question comes down
to is how serious you are,
how committed you are to us.
And I want to see failure
is not an option for them.
They may end up failing,
but they are like,
I want to drive this to success.
So that's what brings me to
events like the Founders World.
KORY JEFFREY: So if you had
to give any sort of advice
to aspiring founders, many
of which are here today,
what is it that
you'd want to impart?
SANJIT DANG: I would tell
them believe in yourself.
Don't go by the experts,
the so-called "experts."
You are the expert.
The things that
we're looking at,
the technologies that we
use today, a lot of them
were rejected by "the
experts" in their time.
PC, when it came
out, somebody said,
why would somebody buy this?
I don't see this selling
beyond 100 units.
Things like that.
iPhone came out.
A big company,
competitor to Google
said, hey, who's going
to buy a $500 phone
to put in his pocket?
No way.
Don't go by the experts.
Experts don't know
what you're doing.
Believe in yourself.
Just keep marching along.
And there will be dark days.
But that's where your vision
and your faith in the vision
comes to save you.
KORY JEFFREY: So we
talked a little bit
about the partnership
between Intel and Google
with the new 3D cameras.
Other than that, what is your
favorite Google technology?
SANJIT DANG: I really
like the Chrome browser.
Search is obviously great.
I use it every day.
But talking beyond search, I
really like the Chrome browser.
And I moved to the browser
probably three plus years ago.
Ever since then, I
have not had any reason
to go back to Mozilla
or Internet Explorer.
If I'm forced to use
Internet Explorer or Mozilla,
for some reason, I
feel like, oh, come on.
Don't send me back.
KORY JEFFREY: That's good.
That's good stickiness there.
SANJIT DANG: And it's the basic,
fundamental strategy of Google
to merge search
bar and the URL bar
into one simple thing
I think was phenomenal.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
Well, thank you very much
for joining me today.
And thank you for
joining me, Kory.
I am on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]